hello everyone
I hope everyone has got admitted into
the rune room welcome to today's webinar
on soft skills is everyone able to hear
me if you are able to hear not hear me
please type in the chat box and we will
see what we can do about it I can see
about 19 people have logged in and
please type your response in the chat
box if you're not able to hear us my
name is mira singh robert i'm
accompanied today by two of my
colleagues as my support partners some
are from india and jackie from us
they'll be doing their magic at the back
end with managing the tech and
moderating the chat for us while we can
see your names but it will be great if
all if you can write on check your
location and if possible the nanodegree
that you are pursuing so that everyone
gets to know each other and connect
later if they want to so welcome once
again and let's begin summer if you see
anybody not able to hear us just point
it out to me please thank you so we
begin with our presentation it's on soft
skills an important aspect of Career
Development as you all can see so we
move on to the slide 2 which is about me
I'm currently located out of India and I
have over 20 years of experience in
senior leadership roles for
multinational large firms and their
captors with focus on banking and
finance services I'm culturally astute
with extensive experience in bringing
together global stakeholders unknown for
mentoring coaching developing
high-performance teams with diverse
capabilities I have consistently
nurtured teens and develop leaders
across my tenure I'm a guest speaker at
India's premier business schools on
persuasive communication and to share
one of the fun facts about me I love
travelling meeting and engaging with
people from different cultures
understanding their interest and
bringing that best experiences so that's
about me let's move on to the next slide
which is about what are the key
takeaways for today once they're in it
for me the normal question which
everyone would like to ask so there are
five key takeaways we'll all
try and understand what soft skills are
what is the importance of soft skills
and career development which soft skills
can enhance employability most important
how we how do we demonstrate since it's
called soft will understand how to
demonstrate them because they are not
like a technical degree that you can
just put on your resume a or show it to
somebody so how do we demonstrate and
last but not the least how do we develop
the soft skills so these are the five
key takeaways that we are going to get
from this webinar moving on to the
agenda slide the agenda slide has five
items and all of them are aligned to the
key takeaways moving to the next slide
why what are some skills so I hope we
all are all on this under on that slide
and yes summer weekend so what comes to
your mind when you think of soft skills
what comes to your mind just think about
it and if you can think of some words
you feel free to put it on the chat box
it'll be good to see whenever we hear
soft skills I'm sure this is not a new
term everybody has heard it before so
it'll be lovely to know oh I can see
quite a few of my students who have
taken coaching sessions which is new
Lamai is new russia all right okay she
says interacting with people Alena
mm-hmm communication skills bingo that's
a big topic and I'll come to it in one
of my slides lovely so yeah I think
welcome Jean I can see you you're doing
your DevOps I can see Zi doing
networking all right so what comes to
your mind when you think of soft skills
now we can click and you will see the
first four examples of soft skills
appearing on the screen I have listed
about 16 of them and I'll keep them on
the slide for you to have a look at them
while I talk to you about what I think
about soft skills well you can refer the
examples of soft skills that are listed
on the slide let me expand and share my
views to get a better understanding on
what are soft skills if you have been
researching ways to get ahead in your
job hunt you may have come across the
term socks
even though the term is used frequently
we may not have fully understood exactly
what it means they're not as easy to
quantify or evaluate but they are just
as valuable
we are not able to learn them at school
or take a course in how to gain them
they can typically come naturally to you
as a person if you're trying to enhance
your resume a opposition yourself
perfectly during your next interview you
should know how to showcase your soft
skills but before you can do that let us
familiarize with what exactly such
skills are so on the next slide we see
that soft skills have been summarized so
soft skills are attributes and behaviors
that are a natural part of your
character like the ability to listen
show empathy think outside the box or
solve problems these skills define us
and our habits they are concerned with
our emotional intelligence and how we
perceive the world soft skills are
defined by how you approach life and
work the way you interact with people
soft skills is an umbrella term that
encompasses everything from social
skills to communication skills to
emotional intelligence and to personal
character traits so that's soft skills
for you I always love to give this
example of sealing versus flow so hard
skills or tech skills set the floor for
a position whereas soft skills often set
the ceiling or how far you can advance
so think about it you're either
qualified to do the day-to-day job or
you are not if the position requires
proficiency in Python you can't really
fake it either you can demonstrate the
proper qualifications or you can't you
might get hired at a firm as an
accountant which presumably requires the
appropriate hard skill degree in
accountancy but if you want to be the
CEO or CFO someday you better combine
the basic talent with additional soft
skills like communication leadership
organization otherwise 40 years from now
you might retire as an entry level
accountant so that is what our soft
skills for us we move on to slide number
nine which is why do soft skills matter
I hope I'm able to everyone yeah we move
to the next slide summer hard skills can
land you to an entry
but you need soft skills to get through
them so we moved to the next slide and
what do we see there we see statistics
we see statistics off various
organizations which I plan to share with
you this slide has statistics from Wall
Street Journal where we can see what
executives have to say about importance
of soft skills and how difficult it is
to find talent with appropriate soft
skills you can read the numbers yourself
it's up there for you employers these
days are rightfully placing more focus
on Bank soft skills when considering if
he or she has the minimum qualifications
for a job and here are some of the
statistics to tell the story moving on
to the next slide we also see what World
Economic Forum and LinkedIn and Harvard
Business and financial times have to say
about soft skills so while y'all read
that let me give you a bit of my view on
why do soft skills matter so why are
soft skills seems so important for many
employers the technical hard skills that
are required for performing a job like
writing a code or completing the monthly
check out adjust the baseline any
employee who wants to fill that role to
be proficient at certain HUD has to be
proficient at certain hard skills that's
the price of entry but it's the soft
skills that's that a rockstar employee
apart from their co-workers an
experienced analyst who gets along with
his or her co-workers who's always on
time and takes pride in his or her work
is more valuable than the one who's
antagonistic and does not and does just
enough to get by even if he or she is
equally proficient in terms of technical
skills so soft skills can even make up
for less than stellar hard skills in
some cases how much does it really
matter if the analyst with the great
attitude is a bit slower in completing
is delivery than the grumpy analyst or
coder think about it
this is
hypothetical example there are many more
roles that an employee plays when he
actually lands into the real corporate
world fair enough we move on to the next
slide which is slide number 12 I have
spoken quite a bit now that we have
understood what our soft skills and by
do they matter it will be good to do a
quick temperature check to do a poll
already for it let's take a quick poll
and see what we feel about ourselves on
whether we have the necessary soft
skills required to ace an interview this
poll is anonymous so please feel free to
respond you have three options as listed
on the slide we will give it a minute or
two for everyone to type out their
response in the chat box and the
responses will come without the names
and summer will bring up the results for
us on what we have so here we go
just answer the first question the
second poll will come later on although
I have put both the poll questions up
there please do not answer the second
poll question now fantastic I think I
can see the numbers increasing awesome
we can see almost 40% of the students
64% of the students feeling that they
are 50/50 which is a great place to be
we have 62% it's good to change our mind
it's good time to know where we are
there are a couple of more slides ahead
and we'll do the second poll at the time
so I think we have done summer and I
think all of you are able to see the
results so we have about 8% which is one
of the participants who is excellent at
soft skills and I'm very happy to have
you here we have 62% who feel they know
50% and they are yet there to reach for
the next 50 and the last one who need
help is about 38% that's why we are here
and we'll continue to have more
workshops on soft skills after this one
as well
Thank You summer for putting this up and
we can take this off now you know just a
small thing so I can see their total
number of students are 22 so only out of
those 22 13 I have participated for this
poll I would really encourage other
students to go ahead and participate can
you put it up on the screen again yeah
it'll be good sorry I just crossed it
out if you can put it back again for me
please
so it's already there students should be
able to access it they would get an
option of opening it and oh yeah I can
see it yes so whoever has not responded
please rest assured this is anonymous
you can see the results yourself we
don't know the names of the students who
have answered and we don't know the
names of the students who have not
answered so that's the beauty if you'll
add we will get some statistics it will
help us to build our workshops based on
this
so we have one more student who has
answered I think we have at least six
more students who can add even if I
leave out my two co-partners and two
co-hosts out of it there are six more
students if y'all can please answer the
poll it will be good the poll is there
over there and I think some of them have
already answered the second poll also
okay so we are where we are 15 of them
have answered fantastic
we have 67% score on 50:50 and we have
40% score on need help if I most
students can respond that will be great
take your time please don't respond to
the second student second poll right now
we will come to that later okay we will
continue with our presentation and our
webinar while students can take their
time to answer the poll so back great I
think this poll gave us some insights
about I'm happy to see some of the
students are at 5050 and some of them
are at need help it's just the beginning
of your career so obviously you know
there is so much more to learn we move
on to slide number 14 and 15 now what do
we see here here's what top
organizations have to say the next two
slides show research reports by five
organizations on the top desired soft
skills that employers are looking for in
their employees so why what soft skills
employers value is the million-dollar
question as you can see on this slide
there is data by eye higher they had
analyzed thirty five million job
postings after which they came up with
this list of top desired soft skills
which the employers are looking for so
it will be interesting for you guys to
know that hiring experts and business
leaders they weigh in on the personality
traits that make the difference between
a strong candidate and a baseline
candidate there are seven types of
personality traits that employers are
looking for in their engagement during
interviews with candy
and you know which are these seven
personality traits are you a multitasker
are you a strategist are you a decider
are you a cautious person are you an
independent thinker are you a team
player and are you a cultural fit these
are some words some personality trait
names which can promote provoke your
thought process all right and all the
examples of soft skills which you see
are an outcome of these seven
personality traits and they have been
given names which are easy to understand
so these are good to have personality
traits and if you are able to display
and demonstrate them
this will help differentiate to be in
the pool of strong candidate for
shortlisting or selections so we see the
next slide which also shows the
statistics of this is an interesting
slide on comparison of seven top career
related organization on most valued
skills you can see that top five skills
have been color-coded for easy reference
across the board for all the seven
organizations communication is in blue
problem-solving is in peach color
flexibility is in gray color work ethic
is in purple and teamwork is in green if
you look at it little more closely you
will find communication cutting across
all the seven organizations so it
appears on all the seven research
reports problem-solving flexibility work
ethic and teamwork they appear on five
out of seven
this gives valuable insight on which top
soft skills are really a must-have to be
successful in our career so I have just
four good record purpose on the next
slide just summarized these five slides
these five most valued soft skills
summer can we go to the next slide yeah
so I've just summarized this for
recapping purpose if you can see out of
all the ten or ten soft skills that
seven organizations had collated after
talking to hundreds of employers the
five
top the list communication
problem-solving flexibility work ethic
and teamwork I may even be doing a next
workshop whenever I do my next workshop
or webinar on deep diving into these
five most valued soft skills so look out
for that then we move on slide number 18
we summarized it now slide slide number
19 time to do a poll here is where we
wanted to put up the second question but
I see quite a few students have already
answered it wow we have seventeen so my
question was would you prefer to be in a
team led by a leader with exceptional
people skills but with not enough tech
or hard skills or the other way around
and I see 88% of the students or
participants voting for a trust me
having been there for 25 years in the
corporate industry it really really
helps to have a leader who has some good
soft skills because he has whole team
whole battalion of people who can
compliment him on the tech skills but
nobody can compliment him on the soft
skills or the people skill or the
interpersonal skills trust me you
wouldn't want a grumpy line manager who
does not have acknowledgement
who does not have realization and value
or who does not know how to express his
gratitude or his thanks to you when you
really deserve it the most so and with
the 89% of the audience because if I had
to answer this poll I would clearly go
with it not because I had worked for two
and a half decades in corporate industry
I think long ago in my life I realized
it's the people who take you along the
skills the tech skills can always be
learned if you have good leaders who are
willing to take you along they will
guide you they will mentor you they will
tell you what you are not good at and
they will help you to upskill but if you
don't have a great leader with you who
doesn't have a foresight who doesn't
want to take people up then you are left
to yourself in fact I had a coaching
student with me and he had an issue
where he said that a
all the freedom in my work they allow me
to do whatever I want and he works with
one of the top banking companies I don't
want to name it and he said my issue is
I want to change my job I said you are
in a dream job most of the students want
would want to be in your place he said
no I do not have a line manager who
pushes me ahead who mentors me or who
can challenge my innovation I need
somebody who can push me to do more and
I don't have that and that is missing I
don't mind going to an organization
which is not among the top five
organizations in the world but I want a
line manager who can mentor me and who
can help me to innovate better so yeah I
would have gone with answer a thank you
for responding and we can take off the
poll results now so we move on to the
presentation and we move on to the next
slide so how do you put your soft skills
on display very important question now
we know what are soft skills we know why
do they matter we know which soft skills
the employers want in us so the next
obvious question is how do we display I
can't go around telling people I'm very
warm by Nature I can cannot go around
telling the interviewer I'm a team
player so how do I display it then
correct all right so we move to the next
slide
soft skills are not so you can read what
is written over here but I'll be sharing
my views along with it the question soft
skills can be the deciding factor
between you and
the candidate getting the job no hiring
manager is ever going to directly ask
you about soft skills in an interview so
it's entirely up to you to showcase them
the secret is to talk about your soft
skills as a part of how you answer the
question how you answer the interview
questions it's a matter of explaining
your answers with a howl statement
rather than just talking about the
result statement while it is still
important to be well versed in technical
skills that apply to your industry it's
equally important to showcase people
skills the trick is to combine those
strengths and abilities on your resume
to truly show a potential employer why
you would be a valuable asset to the
team we can go to the next slide which
tells us the summary and the definition
of how to display the soft skills now
you need to highlight your personality
how do you do that personality traits I
just discussed there are seven
personality traits they are difficult to
demonstrate on a resume a so it's
essential to highlight them during the
interview strategy storytelling can get
your personality across to a hiring
manager sharing stories that demonstrate
how you perform during an experience is
important to help you get across your
personality traits discuss how you
handled yourself in a crisis or how you
showed up as a leader during a positive
or negative time simply stating you're a
team player for instance isn't enough
for most hiring managers instead provide
a concrete instance of when you worked
on a team to accomplish a goal identify
moments of success from your past and
think about rich soft skill ensured its
success example to demonstrate
coordination and teamwork quote that
time when you helped resolve a bug
across DevOps and run teams by setting
up a cross-functional group and
iterating till the solution was reached
put it in the context as to how the bow
can be used for the current position
these are some of the ways to display
your soft skills a lot of coaching a lot
of students who have done coaching
sessions with me I always tell them keep
your five narrative stories ready with
you and when you go for an interview and
when a question is being asked to you
you pull that out from your data bank
and you narrate that incident and I have
also suggested to them to use the star
model okay and those who have done the
coaching session with me would know what
it means so when you keep your
narratives ready when you keep your
stories ready your strategic stories
ready it helps you not only to
demonstrate your tech skills but it also
helps you to narrate and to display your
soft skills all right just be yourself
the most important thing to remember
when walking into an interview is that
it is completely two-sided you are
interviewing them as much as they are
interviewing you have you not found
yourself when you enter into an
interview room you also start judging in
your mind oh my god this person looks
very stiff he looks very tough he may
ask me some tough questions or sample
somebody who comes across very pleasant
very warm very easygoing
you know our mind instantly runs so you
are interviewing them as much as they
are interviewing you so just be yourself
and keep your strategic stories ready
that's the best way to display your soft
skills we move on to the next slides
which are on how to develop soft skills
yeah and there you are
so
just like hard skills soft skills can
also be developed and since they are
related to interpersonal interactions we
can use our three senses to develop our
soft skills what are our three senses
hearing seeing and doing yeah so what do
you do by hearing you get feedback from
your teachers from your mentors from
your counselors from your coaches by
seeing what I mean read read and read
and read three blogs read articles read
the links go go to Google find out more
knowledge is wisdom wisdom is strength
all right
so see last doing it after you have read
or after you have got the feedback it's
not enough you have to action it after
every coaching session we give you
actions and we give you resources so
this is third part is the action after
you have received the feedback and after
you read the articles and after you've
collected what is it that you need to do
you need to set a goal and you need to
execute it right and on the next slide
we will see every soft skill that you
develop will be something you will
eventually draw in your career everyone
possesses a few soft skills that come
naturally to them and they can hone
others that may not come as easily the
versatility of soft skills and the
advantage they can give you in your
career are just part of what puts these
transferable skills in high demand
technical skills usually only apply to a
specific industry but soft skills are a
benefit across many different types of
careers alright our slide last slides
actually lists some of the ways in which
we can develop our soft skills so if you
see the slide which is there right now
on the presentation there are 11 ways
that I have listed that you can develop
your soft skills they may come naturally
to you or you may have to put an effort
to develop them showing empathy today
you are searching for a job there are
some of the P some of the participants
may already be in a job
so when you're already in a job you need
to show empathy for people we feel or
they know it I care there is nothing to
show that I care right but that's wrong
showing empathy is one of the major
areas how you connect with people second
we need to listen and respond we think I
am listening so what if I'm looking at
my phone so what if I'm looking at my
presentation no it's important when
somebody is talking to you to actually
listen to them and respond when you're
required to respond these are some of
these soft skills which people take for
granted especially the Millennials
because they are always so distracted
with technology tools that they think
everything is acceptable but trust me in
a career in a corporate environment
Russia I think your video is on you may
want to put it off we can see you
walking all right so be patient and
display helpfulness how many times it
has happened that somebody is trying to
talk and we have already understood what
the person is trying to say and we
become impatient and we just button and
we try to complete the statement and we
try to say okay let us do it this way we
don't even allow the person to actually
express what he or she is trying to say
this is a soft skill to be able to be
patient to hear out the person
completely before trying to give your
views or your opinions it's a daily life
thing whether at home in your personal
life or in a professional life I see it
so so often with my teenager daughter
she's 19 and you know before even I have
completed at times she tends to answer
and I tell her you didn't hear me you
didn't hear the last part you never know
what I'm going to say in the last part
and your answer may change so be patient
and display helpfulness most important
thing lot of people know when to talk
but they don't know when to keep quiet
and that goes a long way in a career I
have experienced it all along throughout
my career especially in my meetings and
my boardrooms know when and how to ask
the right question I'm not saying be
apprehensive and pull yourself back no
no
no question is stupid but the timing can
be wrong you need to be right on your
timing so know when and how to ask the
question be approachable lot of time
what happens you may be excellent worker
you may be an excellent human being but
your body language the nonverbal
language which is one of the soft skills
and the communications may come across
as you're not approachable and if you're
not approachable people will not connect
with you if people will not connect with
you you will not be able to network if
you're not able to network you will not
be able to grow the most important thing
when you land a job and you get into a
work space is that you need to come
across to people very very approachable
because it's a new place it's you who
needs to make friends or make colleagues
and understand and know them so be
approachable keep an open mind many
times people will behave people will
write emails people will react in a
particular manner maybe they have been
there for a longer time and they know
what next is going to happen don't jump
to conclusions have an open mind
think about it sleep over a night and
then react to it that is a very
important soft skill to keep an open
mind it's very easy to react to
something all right very very easy I
don't like something I will switch it
off I can't understand this I will not
go through this he didn't tell me I
won't do it no because it's not about
just performing this task or being
successful in this job it's about honing
this skill and taking it forward in your
life too next job and to your life and
ahead in your career so have an open
mind solving problems together
I had one very major problem in one of
my career points where I was presented
with a situation where the CEO of the
company had gone and given out given out
his email id on a interview because one
of the participants challenged him that
all you big leaders talk big things but
when it comes to actually helping people
out if I ask you for your personal email
ID you will not give it to me
so our CEO here out his email ID and
immediately came out of the interview
and he called me I was heading the
escalations team then it was long back
about 18 years ago and he said Mira I
have given out my email id you can
expect whole flood of complaints
customer complaints coming in and I want
all of these to be resolved in 24 hours
I was like I have a team of only eight
people and we are a 25,000 footprint
organization and we have millions of
customers all over the globe and you're
trying to tell me that no matter how
many complaints come in you want them
resolved in 24 hours but you don't say
that to the CEO the CEO is one-way
communication he just made that
statement and he put the phone down and
I sat there for five minutes at my desk
and 18 years ago I was not so senior I
had not seen so much of life I had not
developed myself so much I did get
nervous I was lost and I didn't know
what to do so at that time I came up
with this solution I went ahead and
called for emergency meeting with all
the executive directors of the company
and they all came and I had given the
title of the meeting what it is they
understood the gravity they all came and
I very clearly shared with them the
problem statement this is what the CEO
has said and already 300 complaints are
poured in by the time via meeting this
will go on for probably a week and after
this this will die down but we have to
manage the show for one week so what did
we do I told them look a customer
complaint is an outcome of operationally
some process having broken down and it
is one of your shots
it could be sales it could be marketing
it could be compliance it could be risk
it would be operations it could be
anything but the fact that there is some
process which has broken down that is
why a customer complaint has come it is
not a creation of my team so it will be
in your interest if my team sends that
complaint to you your team can
immediately resolve it we are not going
to do the root cause right now we are
just going to give the solution to this
to the to the complaint person the
person who is complaining
this will help two ways one we will be
able to keep up the brand name and two
you will not get the
for your shop not being in order and
three after this all has subsided we
will have enough data to do root cause
analysis and to fix our processes so
that these problems don't really so when
you solve problems together when you
bring people together you tell them your
intent you show your passion you show
your intent and you show that you're
contributing and you roll up your
sleeves and you work with them that is a
great soft skill people will always
respect it people will always be helpful
and people will be willing to go that
extra mile for you it works for me and
I'm talking about eighteen years ago
when I wasn't so senior but I did have
the courage and the clarity in my mind
of going ahead and making sure that we
solve this problem so solving problems
together is a great soft skill to have
be creative not repetitive have a
strategy for everything be accountable
and on your own how many of us actually
in other jobs in our personal life own
the complete piece we all think okay my
my role is only this much I will do this
rest of the things some other coder has
to do some other analyst has to do you
know what at an early age if you start
looking at the whole piece together
maybe in the earliest you may be putting
extra effort but you know what you will
gain you will gain a lot of knowledge
and expertise which you can start
displaying in your future jobs and in
your future interviews which opportunity
you won't get it's only at the entry
level usually that people try to put
more work on you don't deflect it try to
take as much as you can because this is
going to hone your skills if you have
that extra time if you can go that extra
mile pick up the extra skills that are
being thrown at you and this will make
you develop your soft skill of being
accountable okay and eventually you will
start owning your role when you become a
team leader on it or when you become a
leader okay last manage tasks and
resources obviously when you reach a
very senior position you have to manage
your tasks and most important your
resources if you don't manage your
resources when I say resources you
budget if you go outside your budget
nobody is going to come and give you the
budget whether you are at an entry level
or you are at the senior-most level you
all have a budget for everything so you
have to manage and you have to plan in
advance how do I reach from position a
to position Z within this year with
these resources for example your law
students you are trying to search for a
job what ir resources you have Udacity
as a resource you may be having your
your student councils you may be having
your peers you may be having your
network these are your resources now
with these resources within six months
time what is it that you want to achieve
so manage your tasks and your resources
within the timeline and you will be able
to get the most out of it so these are
some of the soft skills that can be
developed and this brings us to the end
of our session and I would like to
complete my presentation and webinar
with the same statement ceiling versus
floor hard skill set the floor for a
position but soft skills often set the
ceiling for how far you can advance
that's great that's where we are and
that brings us to the question and
answer session now it would be very very
unfair if I don't let my students bring
up their questions and here are 15 20
minutes for y'all to put up your
questions and summer and Jackie are
going to help us moderate the chat all
yours the show is all yours now please
go ahead
you
okay I can see LeMay how to show our
soft skills in a resume a soft skills
cannot be shown on a resuming but it can
be displayed when you go for an
interview and you have to answer the
questions by giving your narrator by
giving a story which brings out so if
you look at a couple of slides that I
have presented now that will help you so
on the resume a it may not be possible
yes you can say I have managed a team so
the moment you write the word manage the
team they know that you have the skill
of managing people yeah so that's one
way of showing the other way of showing
is if you have completed a large-scale
project where you have dealt with
cross-functional stakeholders you can
you can narrate it or you can write it
in your resume a by saying delivered a
large-scale cross-functional program
with multiple stakeholders requiring
high communication skills so that brings
out that you have great communication
skills that's why you were able to
deliver a very large-scale
cross-functional program the moment you
use the word cross-functional it means
that you have great communication skills
so you have to look out for keywords
resume a key words for soft skills if
you google it you will be able to find a
lot of key words which you can display
on your resume it okay what if you have
two senior managers asking you to do
something at work but you have priority
work to do with your current team okay
so are we saying here that I'm
unreadiness question here now what if
you have two senior managers asking you
to do something at work but you have
priority work to do with your current
team that's where you have to manage
your tasks and your resources you cannot
say no to your two seniors because I
don't know if you have gone through the
time management model in that something
is called me and something it's I and
you so whenever your senior tells you to
do something important it is for your
development and whenever you
to do something further for the team
it's for them and both are very
important for your career you will have
to go you'll have to burn the candle at
times at both the ends you have to sit
and have a conversation with all the
three your team and the two senior
stakeholders you'll have to prove and
evidence that how you will prioritize
the first and the second and the third
and you will still deliver on all the
three roles it's not that you're saying
no you're just saying I will first do
one and then I'll do the second and then
I'll do the third and you will give a
justification that this can wait while
this cannot wait because it has a share
shareholder value impact or it has some
delivery impact so you have to first
show the intent yes I will do it I have
two more burning issues if you allow me
can I do them and come back to you I
will finish it in today's time by
so-and-so time so this is how I have
handled but if I know more about the
question in detail I'll be able to
answer better so maybe you can put this
question on student hub or maybe you can
put it come over for a coaching session
and we can discuss that situation Mara
we've got a question from Russia and she
says she finds it difficult or hard to
ask her the people for advice so do you
have any special tips that we can share
with her here okay she says she finds it
difficult to ask people for advice okay
yeah
so that is Russia one of your soft
skills issue you are not having so one
of the soft skills that I have written
on my last slide is having an open mind
let me tell you one thing Russia no
question is stupid never ever
underestimate yourself it'll take only
once or twice for your inhibition to go
and don't think in your mind that if I
go to ask advice I may be little myself
or the other person may think I don't
understand anything in fact it takes a
lot more courage to go out and ask for
help and if the other person is matured
enough he or she will welcome it and
will go the extra mile to not only
advise you on what you're asking
he or she may guide you on
different perspective and different
dimension as well all together try it
and let me know I'll be keen to wait to
hear just make that first move and I am
very sure you'll be able to break that
inhibition in you mirror a question in
from anis I believe um Annie analyst is
asking what are the soft skills needed
in IT jobs where IT roles
I guess mirror that's a combination
really isn't it yes absolutely Jackie so
Jackie is also one of the career coaches
you may be seeing her on hotline chat
she comes and check her out on the
events calendar I think she comes same
as my day or maybe the next day soft
skills as I mentioned during the webinar
are transferable skills any soft skill
that you have developed can be used in
all your jobs whether it's a tech job or
it's a non tech job how can you not use
communication skills in a tech job how
can you not use a team player in a tech
job how can you not use problem-solving
soft skill in a tech job how can you not
use empathy in a in a tech job so there
is no specific soft skills for tech
industry soft skills encompass our
personality it encompasses our personal
interaction levels it it it displays our
personality traits so there are no
specific soft skills for any industry
they are applicable across the board any
other question Jackie and summer so a
question from is it lemme how to manage
stress before the interview that's an
excellent question
so it's the same before coming for this
webinar all right we all experience it's
a lovely question and you may be seeing
me smiling already on the screen okay
it's good to have the right level of
stress with the new because that keeps
you on your toes it keeps you alert it
keeps you you know agile before coming
on this webinar I had that butterflies
in my stomach although I have given so
many presentations throughout my tenure
the reason I am not able to see you guys
I have never given a presentation where
I can't see my audience so I was like
how do I know that I'm lagging well with
my people how do I know that they are
listening to me how do I know somebody's
not sleeping how do I know somebody's
not listening to something else so it's
good to have the right amount of stress
level but not you know it's like the
blood pressure if it goes about high
blood pressure is not good and low blood
pressure is not good we need to have the
right momentum coming back to your
question how do you handle stress
obviously you have to tell yourself what
you know nobody else knows because the
question which they are going to ask you
only you have the right answer for it
because you have done it so go with that
winner attitude
I know what I have done better than
anybody else and the fact that they have
invited me for the interview it means I
have some skills and some experience
which they want to explore for hiring so
I am good and I will be good when I am
there to answer any of the questions and
if at all any question comes up which
you think you are not comfortable with
there is nothing wrong in saying let me
take a moment to think about it nobody
is going to crucify you for it nobody is
going to think oh he is not agile or he
couldn't answer immediately you can
always frame your statements by saying
well this is a great question but let me
just think about it and by that time an
answer be brief tell yourself you're
good look into the mirror and say I'm
the best that's the best way to do it
and by the way these days there are
coaches now available which is called
coach in your pocket so I have a lot of
students who call me and they say I have
an interview in half an hour so that's
another story
but there are many tools available if
you can't manage your self then you need
you can take help from external tools
and external coaches on it any other
question
summer or yes so really there is one
question that says
how so this is this question is from
Nicola says if you don't know an answer
to a question during an interview how
can we express it ah I answered it
without seeing a question sweetheart so
if you don't know honestly if you don't
know the answer at all if it is a domain
that you have don't have an experience
at all don't fake it just don't fake it
because you the person who's
interviewing you has much more
experience than you he'll be able to see
you through it
be honest about it and you can't not
have eight on ten answers if you have
been asked ten questions you can't not
have eight answers right you may not
have one or two questions for which you
don't have answer and if it's genuinely
a tech question or something that you
don't have hands-on experience you
should not fake it you should be honest
and you should say I don't have an
experience on this but from what I have
read and what I have heard in my
networking activities I think probably
this should be the answer correct me if
I'm wrong this way you're inviting the
other person to help you understand and
gather information on the question on
which you don't have knowledge so even
if you don't clear that round you would
have come out a little more
knowledgeable and you can use that
answer in your next interview with
somebody else sounds good Nikhil great I
hope you agree to that also there is one
question posted by inez he's Heelys he's
asking you know whether he could how you
know what's the best way to put stopped
skill certificates on the resume is it
fairly helpful and enough to show that
you know that the candidate was really
master in some soft skills is it really
helpful in a way so is he trying to say
that he has soft skill certificates and
he wants he's asking whether he can put
it up on his resuming right I think it
may be an example wherein someone had
participated in a leadership program or
oh absolutely absolutely absolutely you
need to call it out under your skills or
under your education under your
certifications absolutely these days and
lawyers are looking for people with
specialized skills especially students
or participants or candidates who have
undergone a formal training so I myself
went to Singapore for a training on
leadership and I put it up on my
resuming up front because it takes a lot
to be there first of all to be selected
and to undergo and you come out as a
changed person so if you have
certifications and you have undergone
trainings please put it up under your
certifications great thanks a lot for
addressing that also so number one has a
question he says he's he you know he
faces problem when there is actually he
you know whenever he needs to respond to
into a larger audience or when there is
a lot of people in front of him so he
feels that kind of people pressure and
all that kind of like you mentioned
butterflies before the webinar so that's
that's the challenge that if he is what
can he do to overcome this fear of you
know people speaking in a public forum
or when there is a larger audience yeah
so this is kind of called Nick what's
the name numb and numb and so this is
kind of called as th try it okay you may
not be standing on a stage but your this
whole world is a stage okay
and we are performers at any point of
time whether you're going to watch a
movie the people who are waiting for
someone they are looking at you whether
you go for a dinner people are watching
you whether you go for a meeting people
are watching you whether you go for a
seminar people are watching you so we
are always being observed okay
so first of all we have to get used to
getting comfortable in our skin we have
to get comfortable in in understanding
and telling ourselves I am unique this
is who I am and people will surely
accept me if I'll start accepting myself
see this is a very deep question this
definitely requires a lot of discussion
but if I have to just give you one tip
you have to start standing in front of
the mirror and start talking and talking
and looking at yourself because it's
only 220 percent of what we talk okay
listen to me carefully it's only 20
percent of the content that we talk the
80 percent is the magic of our body
language
okay if you get your body language right
the confidence will come in people will
get attracted people will listen to you
people will understand people will
automatically want to be there and hear
you so 80% is soft skills when you are
out there in middle of the people and
the only way to hone that skill is to
practice and probably even to go for one
training one or two trainings so there
are online free trainings available
there is peer-to-peer help available you
can google and find out those links and
you must take one short training there
are a lot of trainings which are
available where they teach you how to
come out of that public speaking fear so
go ahead and just explore some of the
public speaking courses they are just
one-day seminars and I'm sure that will
help you so I think that's a we have
answered all the questions so guys if
you have any questions we still have
time left I would really encourage
everyone if you have any questions that
is related to this webinars please do so
even if it's not related the webinar we
still have time so I hope we can
accommodate somebody see I see one
question from jean-marc and the question
is like Russia
I feel difficult to reach out to people
and ask for help I have over 20 years of
work experience and returning to IT
after a break several years I fear that
people will judge me as weak if I ask
for help so gene you are only weak till
the time you think you are weak you know
how many people out there in the job
actually don't don't know their job but
they fake it how they fake it by having
a personality by having the soft skills
which shows they know it all and you
know how they learn they learn by
networking they learn by coming and
talking to people they get their work
done and they showed and they take the
credit which is not the right way to do
it but I have seen tons of people even
at the level of vice president and I had
to literally get three or four wise
presidents chucked out of the
organization because I kept observing
them they knew nothing
and I'm talking of Technology company I
was the chief operating officer in my
last role last year when one of the
leading European banks and I was hiding
the Technology Center there and trust me
today the trend has changed in my times
going and asking people for help people
would show you down but today if you
notice even on your career section then
any student is asking a question I am so
pleased to see so many students jumping
in and answering that question they
don't even wait for the coaches to come
because coaches come at their scheduled
time so the trend has changed the
Millennials do not judge if you tell
them hey hey bro I don't understand this
can you please help me and they will not
only tell you the answer to that they'll
give you two or three more things which
will help you explore and increase your
horizon just do it once and see just do
it twice and see and trust me
write an email to me how it went and if
you still didn't get through let me see
what I can do for you
okay Jean I hope that helps Mary you've
got a question from LeMay again so
you're being asked can you advise how to
set goals to improve on soft skills and
then and which soft skills exactly would
you encourage us to have and how thank
you great summer can you put up just
that slide where I had I'll tell you the
slide number probably the five the five
skills the five summarize top skills go
back go back yes yes yes yes that's it
so that yeah what was the name Jackie
sorry I didn't get the name Naaman is it
is lamby lamby lamby these are the five
top skills that you need to develop
because this is an outcome of a lot of
statistics and lot of research that
seven top career related organizations
have done with hundreds and thousands of
employers and these are the common ones
all right if you can develop these five
top skills soft skills you have arrived
now your question was how to set a goal
right it's like this if I want to lose
weight
I can decide what I'm going to eat how
much I'm going to work out how much I'm
going to run correct nobody else can
come and help me on this right I'll go
I'll go and sneak and eat something it
will not help me so if you you are the
only person who knows how much time do
you have in a day that you can genuinely
put aside for developing a soft skill we
all think we will cross the bridge when
it comes my dear the bridge will come
and it will go under you and you will
not come to know always be prepared in
all my coaching sessions I say pre
preparatory steps are very crucial if
you don't do the pre preparatory steps
you will not be able to get the right
result for your action so you set a goal
by when do you want to be excellent in
communication so if you set a date then
you go backwards and then you will start
exploring what does communication mean
it has verbal it has five senses that's
a large topic I will be covering that in
my next workshop so you set a goal and
you you don't have to be very aggressive
if you think you don't have the time
it's okay take four weeks give yourself
four weeks I think that's more than
enough to hold it at 50% we are not
talking about doing hundred percents I
cannot say that I am 100% good at all
the soft skills the human tendencies
come up I may become impatient at time
depending on the situation you never
know it doesn't mean I don't have the
soft skills it only means that I'm not
able to control myself and that
particular moment so set the goal based
on your comfort of course push yourself
don't be so comfortable I will complete
it in six months by that time you may
land a job and you may not be successful
at it because you lack communication
skills so two things these are the five
top skills you set a goal you set the
time aside and then if you need help you
either set up a coaching session with
any one of the coaches or you go for one
of the training seminars which is
available in York location mirror a
really good question has come in from
grab it's about telephone interviews so
how do I present myself and for an
interview
communication-wise so I think Europe
where you're coming from probably is how
can you come across communication wise
when you're having a telephone interview
very good question
why don't you try one thing so there is
a link I don't have it handy right now
but it's peer to peer interviewing all
right so where you actually dial in to
appear and he asks you questions and you
answer that you record that for yourself
and hear it and you will realize how is
your pitch how is your tone how are you
landing did you mean to say what you
said did you cover everything that you
wanted to say or did you miss out it
will tell you the speed of your thought
and the speed of your speech it will
tell you the tone and it will tell you
how it landed and also when your peer
answers you the questions you will hear
him also that will give you an
experience of how when you are talking
on a telephone interview how you are
landing so there is a two-way process
one you record yourself and you hear how
you have spoken second when your peer is
answering the questions you hear him and
you try to understand what he could have
done right or what you could have done
if you were in his place I hope this
answers your question
I think a summer we have come to an end
we have just one minute left I can take
one more question right sorry okay so
this is from critical it says um she
okay so you know she's a full-time
homemaker and she's planning to start
her career in a 90 she completed her so
she wants to understand how could she
just define the long break that she had
you know while you know being married
and then completing and now starting a
kid I think that's a very common
question that we find especially for
women who after the marriage they want
to resume the work or after the kids
they won't resume the work but they
sometimes lack the better explanation of
what you know what they wanted to do how
they're actually would be more you know
helpful in the company okay I have taken
a break twice in my life and this is the
third time I have taken a break I've
taken a break last year from my
corporate world and I am sharpening my
saw because I want to study and I want
to do something more and who knows
probably you know yours time I may be
back again with a big bang into the
corporate industry when my child was
born what's the name Haleh I can see
that's the name on summer paula is the
name
I don't know what's critical it's
critical okay so cryptic ah when my
daughter was born incidentally my
daughter's name is critical critical my
when my daughter was born I took a break
of five years and I had this fear in my
mind oh my god five years is like half a
decade and so many more graduates have
come in with so many more new technology
tools and knowledge I'll be like one old
hag over there and how will I sit with
them and give an interview that comes in
our mind but you know one thing that we
have which they don't have they do not
have the life experience which we have
and the life experience is never taught
in any theory in any book in any forum
it comes with life experiencing life and
that looks and comes out in our persona
if you have your qualifications and your
experience in the right place and if you
are eligible for the eligibility
criteria which is laid out in the Job
Description do not underestimate
yourself your gravitas your persona your
life experience will make you stand
apart from the rest of the people tell
it depends on the organization what they
want to put their stakes on whether they
want to put stakes on somebody who's
just a fresher or has one has less
experience or somebody who is holistic
person who has experience life and also
has the tech skills that they are
looking for so don't hesitate just go
out and give yourself a try and you will
be surprised that these were unfounded
unfounded fears because I have been
there and I have done it so I'm telling
you out of experience thank you for
asking that question thank you all for
coming here it was really interesting
and this was very very interactive and
that is what makes a speaker or a coach
happy it would be it would it would be
incomplete if I was the only person
talking here you were a lovely audience
thank you for the poll answers thank you
for the questions and I hope you all got
something out of this webinar I may be
coming up with another webinar next
month and I will definitely put it up on
the student hub
thank you have a good day in whichever
location you are somewhere and Jackie
all were awesome summer without you I
wouldn't have been able to display my
presentation and Jackie without you I
wouldn't have been able to answer my
questions I look forward to supporting
you both in your
seminars have a good day bye bye and God
bless
yeah thanks Mina thanks a lot for this
wonderful session and thanks everyone
for participating and also Jaggi thanks
a lot when we have that you did in on
stringing and picking up the Russians
thanks again guys bye guys